[Music]
on this Monday night Russia's Revenge
Rockets rain down on Ukraine
after the bombing of a key bridge the
despair the devastation and the reaction
from around the world Fiona's
consequences for a critical industry oh
that's something we've never seen before
the fishing sector's unprecedented
challenges the high cost of being
treated for cancer in Canada I would
have to jump through all of these hoops
and that's just not fair the inequity
and access to potentially life-saving
medication and that fighting Spirit they
never even thought that it was possible
the BC wrestler redefining the
competition
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
Russia has launched its broadest attack
on Ukraine since the start of the war at
least 14 people were killed and 97
injured
[Music]
flurry of deadly missile strikes
targeted Bridges and residential
high-rises in at least 11 cities across
the country including the capital the
nation's Energy System has been crippled
with five regions completely in the dark
Russian President Putin says the assault
is Revenge for a deadly blast over the
weekend on a key bridge linking Russia
and Crimea our Europe bureau chief
Crystal gomancing Reports on the intense
shelling and what some ukrainians are
calling another Putin miscalculation and
a warning some of the images may be
disturbing
Monday morning [ __ ] missile strikes
launched by Russia rained down in a
barrage of attacks across Ukraine the
popular Footbridge wasn't directly hit
but there were many other strikes in the
capital with deadly results
in his nightly update Ukraine's
president
urged citizens to listen to the air raid
sirens saying Russia can't win on the
battlefield and so they resort to Terror
they want to destroy our people our
infrastructure everything I really don't
know and I'm extremely angry the strikes
come after a section of the Kirch Bridge
was bombed Saturday Ukraine has not
taken responsibility the bridge connects
Russia with Crimea it was built after
the illegal annexation of the Ukrainian
Peninsula and was a pet project of
Vladimir Putin's if Russia intended to
strike fear into the hearts of
ukrainians with Monday's attacks it
appears to have instead hardened their
resolve
people Sheltering in Metro stations
didn't cower but croont
what I'm seeing now is that people are
just you know rallying around the idea
that these attacks are they're brutal
but they're you know they're they're not
sensible they're useless from the
military standpoint 11 Heating and power
stations in eight regions of the country
were damaged Ukraine has been forced to
Halt energy exports and some cities will
experience rolling blackouts until
repairs are made
the Ukrainian president said Russia
fired 84 cruise missiles Ukraine managed
to intercept 43 of them an additional 24
Russian drones were also deployed 13
destroyed by Ukrainian forces
Belarus meanwhile is now actively
participating with Russia President
Alexander lukashenka ordered troops to
deploy with Russian forces near Ukraine
saying Kiev and its Western backers pose
a threat to his country but he did not
elaborate
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Putin's retaliation for Saturday's
bombing was widely feared the European
Union calls it a war crime prime
minister Trudeau says Russia must be
held accountable and today he spoke to
the president of Ukraine Trudeau
expressed his condolences for Russia's
attacks and says Canada will support
Ukraine as long as necessary as Redmond
Shannon reports the brutal escalation
has triggered widespread condemnation
from Ukraine's Western allies
[Music]
as soon as the first missiles landed
there was little doubt that Russia's
airstrikes were in response to
Saturday's Kirch Bridge explosion
Vladimir Putin confirmed his motives in
a meeting with his Security Council
it is simply impossible to leave crimes
of this kind unanswered if attempts to
carry out acts of terrorism on our
territory continue Russia's response
will be harsh ahead of Tuesday's
emergency GN Summit prime minister
Justin Trudeau called the attacks
reprehensible pledging continued
military assistance and U.S President
Joe Biden said America would support
Ukraine for as long as it takes what we
have to do definitely deliver air
defense from from the Allies side so
that the ukrainians can protect their
cities their civilians peering across
the border to Russia estonia's prime
minister met with the head of the
European commission Monday Russia once
again has shown to the world what it
stands for it is Terror and brutality
those who are responsible have to be
held accountable but European solidarity
is not total EU member hungry announcing
it will help russia-friendly Serbia by
building a pipeline to bypass sanctions
Asian Giants China and India say they
hope for a de-escalation in Ukraine soon
delhi's foreign minister koi on this
week's U.N vote to condemn Russia's
illegal annexation in Ukraine as a
matter of prudence and policy we don't
predict our votes in advance last month
India's prime minister Narendra Modi
openly told Putin today is not an era of
War perhaps a rising sign of impatience
from India despite its Reliance on
Moscow for oil and arms Redmond Shannon
Global News London
in Iran protests over the death of Masa
amini have reached the country's key oil
industry
social media appear to show workers at a
major petrochemical plant carrying out a
threat to strike it's the first sign the
unrest has reached the nation's most
crucial sector the demonstration is in
solidarity with a nationwide movement it
was sparked by the death of 22 year old
amini she was in the custody of Iran's
so-called morality police accused of
improperly wearing her hijab
I'll show you
[Applause]
this morning the sound of apparent
gunshots and explosions echoed through
the capital of Iran's Kurdistan Province
I mean he was Kurdish and her death has
been felt strongly in the region where
demonstrations began at her funeral on
September 17th at least 185 people have
died in the crackdowns on
anti-government protests according to a
norway-based Human Rights group
Canada sport Minister Pascal Saint
Thomas says the weekend decision by the
interim chair of Hockey Canada Andrea
Skinner to resign is a step in the right
direction but as David Aiken reports she
and many others say much more still
needs to be done to change hockey
culture in Canada
fans of professional hockey are looking
forward to the Marquee matchups this
week that will open the NHL season but
hockey fans are also Keen to see the
sports governing body in Canada make
more changes more quickly it isn't
happening fast enough liberal MP Chris
Biddle and MPS from all parties have
been unanimous meaningful change does
not mean just switching out board
members it means changing management it
would be good to see others I think more
important the senior leadership of
Hockey Canada needs to step down sport
Minister Pascal Saint Ange issued a
statement late Sunday saying the
departure of Hockey Canada's interim
board chair Andrea Skinner was a step in
the right direction it must now be
followed she continued by a process of
meaningful change in Hockey Canada's
values and culture we hope that the
remaining members work actively toward
the transition to a new leadership and
governance team one a former hockey
candidate chair agrees there's been no
accountability and the board is not
holding the people accountable for the
decisions that are being made in the
meantime the list of sponsors
withdrawing their support has lengthened
the latest to pull away Nike it was one
of four Hockey Canada Premier Partners
along with Imperial oil Telus and Tim
Hortons all have now paused or ended
their relationship with Hockey Canada
Hockey Canada can get back if it makes
the Right Moves if it hires the right
people and is honest about what has
happened and what needs to be done
companies will come back provincial
associations have also withheld funds
hockey Newfoundland and Labrador became
the latest to do so over the weekend
joining hockey Ontario hockey Quebec and
others but so far hockey Alberta and
hockey BC have not withheld funding
though some have called on them to do so
BC hockey can I think play a key role if
they step up now and decide to follow
where the other provincial federations
have headed hockey Alberta said Friday
it may yet withhold funds but first it
too wants answers and action from Hockey
Canada David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
people living in Atlantic Canada and
Eastern Quebec are still taking stock
more than two weeks after a monster
storm devastated their communities
post-tropical storm Fiona destroyed
homes and knocked out power to much of
the region crews are still working to
restore electricity in parts of pei and
Nova Scotia Fiona also damaged a
critically important industry on the
East Coast Ross Lord has more on the
impacts to the fishing sector
The Harbor at bird Island's Newfoundland
is one of almost 100 in Atlanta Canada
that were damaged by Fiona fishing sheds
and other structures that stood up to
nature for Generations absorbed into the
ocean by an immense storm surge and
Harvesters have their fishing gear in
them lobster traps Harvesters have all
these tools and and related items that
they use for their work in these
buildings and the storm surge and the
waves came in and just took several of
the harbors just took everything more
than a dozen warves on the East Coast
were destroyed many others were damaged
and millions of dollars worth of fishing
traps and other equipment was lost
losses that are largely uninsured oh
that's something we've never seen before
Harvesters are looking at the 300
million dollar Recovery Fund announced
by the Prime Minister last week to help
them rebuild but the storm is forcing
people who've never doubted their life's
work to think twice about their uneasal
alliance with the ocean I think the
perspective on not only where we live
and what we do but who we are has kind
of changed after this storm reinforcing
fears about the impact of climate change
and moving preventative measures to the
Forefront these sheds and stuff have
been there for 100 years and
you know uh so what they'll learn
there's no doubt about that people are
going to be building fire with Supply
chains backed up and replacement
material more expensive than ever the
economic rebuild from Fiona's
Devastation will take a while
Ross Lord Global News
the countdown is on to a critical vote
in the U.S coming up what's making next
month's midterm elections so
unpredictable plus laid to rest funerals
begin for the victims of the Thailand
daycare Rampage
in the U.S voters are less than a month
away from heading to the polls for
crucial midterm elections Republicans
had thought they could regain control of
Congress instead many races are too
close to call and even pollsters are
unsure who will control the balance of
power after November 8th as Jackson
prosco reports both parties are rushing
to shore up support with very different
messages
as control of Congress hangs in the
balance a man who's not on the ballot
could decide which party wins both the
House and Senate Republicans are saying
that their vote in November is going to
reflect more of what they think about
President Trump and Democrats are saying
exactly the same thing we're going to
take back America former president
Donald Trump has put himself front and
center in the midterms turning what's
typically a referendum on the incumbent
president and party into another
election all about Trump it's looking
like a lot of Americans are really tired
of Donald Trump's lies about the 2020
election and aren't going to be too Keen
to vote for some of those people in
November Trump has backed dozens of
so-called election deniers and is
looking back not forward but many of
those candidates are turning out to be a
problem for republicans in Georgia the
trump-backed candidate for Senate
Herschel Walker is embroiled in
controversy
strictly anti-abortion Walker faces
allegations he paid for an abortion for
an ex-girlfriend the abortion thing is
false it's a lot Trump's picks in other
key states are in trouble too
all while Democrats see an uptick in
voter registration fueled by the Supreme
Court decision on abortion and the
popularity of President Biden's policies
like student debt forgiveness
Republicans take control of the Congress
these historic victories we just won for
the American people are going to be
taken away
in this unusual and unpredictable
election year holsters are increasingly
reluctant to make predictions less than
one month from election day it's clear
many races and the balance of power will
come down to the wire
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
a Canadian parliamentary delegation
traveled to Taiwan this weekend to show
support for the island despite the
tension stirred up with China after U.S
House speaker Nancy Pelosi's trip there
in August as part of their tour the five
members led by Toronto MP Judy scrow
attended taiwan's National Day
Celebrations when asked about the
significance of the visit earlier prime
minister Justin Trudeau said China's
position on Taiwanese Independence is
troubling China considers Taiwan to be a
part of its territory and responded to
Pelosi's visit with a series of
provocative military drills in the
strait
funerals are now underway for the 36
victims mostly children killed in a
massacre at a daycare facility in
Northern Thailand Buddhist monks led the
ceremonies as grieving parents said
goodbye to their kids the attacker also
killed his wife and son before ending
his own life officials say he had
recently been fired from his job as a
police officer after he was caught with
methamphetamines Thailand's prime
minister has responded to the attacks by
ordering a strict clampdown on drugs and
drug dealers as well as tightening gun
control rules
ahead the age Gap in cancer treatment
why some young Canadians face huge
hurdles accessing life-saving
medications
when a young Canadian is diagnosed with
cancer the cost of treatment should be
the last thing on their mind but when it
comes to accessing life-saving drugs in
Canada it turns out age does matter
because there's no National Drug
insurance plan those without private
coverage are at the mercy of provincial
rules and as Jamie Maraca explains the
disparity can put patients in expensive
life or death situations
32 year old Rebecca Grundy is beating
the odds it's almost four years to the
day where I woke up uh on a stretcher in
a hospital hallway after suffering from
three Grandma seizures the cause a grade
four glioblastoma an extremely
aggressive form of brain cancer with one
of the lowest survival rates typically
less than 18 months it's most commonly
seen in adults over the age of 45.
Grundy was just 28 when she found out
about her tumor and in Ontario the drugs
she needed to survive an at-home
treatment called tamazolamide isn't
covered for patients her age I would
have to jump through all of these hoops
as a young person under the age of 65 to
get access to this treatment that is
supposed to kill the cancer cells and
save my life and that's just not fair
Grundy spent weeks waiting for
provincial assistance time many of these
patients don't have that's the most
devastating situation when the most
effective the most convenient the best
tolerated treatment just no longer
becomes an option and we have to use an
inferior treatment with more toxicities
in Atlantic provinces patients face a
similar Patchwork of drug coverage
meanwhile in Quebec private or public
insurance will cover the cost and in
Canada's Western provinces take home
Cancer drugs and hospital-administered
cancer drugs are treated equally this
means most patients get the medication
doctors prescribe them immediately but
even that access comes with caveats 36
year old Megan goit was diagnosed with
stage four breast cancer last year she
was prescribed limparza another at-home
medication with less severe side effects
but in Alberta the 8 500 a month cost is
only covered for ovarian and prostate
cancers without her husband's private
insurance the mother of one says she
likely wouldn't be alive today I was
really really really scared that that I
wasn't going to be able to see him
graduate kindergarten thanks to this
draw and how amazing
it is working for me it is extended my
longevity like quite a bit at Ontario's
legislature there have been Promises of
policy change but no immediate action
we're frustrated we had hoped that our
Cancer Care System would have evolved
and tried to keep Pace
um with how cancer treatment is changing
Advocates say this should also include
speedier approvals from Health Canada
keeping Pace with developments South of
the Border during the pandemic we were
seeing young people with aggressive
breast cancer crossing the U.S border to
try to access treatment because the
stakes are so high Grundy and lobbyist
is focusing on her Province pushing
Ontario's Health Ministry to do better
for other patients it's important that
these people have the best shot at life
fighting not just for her own but for
everyone else who will need treatment
regardless of age Jamie moroccer Global
News Toronto
inspiring fight next how the comeback
story of a jiu jitsu competitor in BC is
creating a buzz in the martial arts
world
finally tonight an incredible comeback
by Jiu Jitsu competitor in BC proving
not even the bullets that knocked him
down in a 2017 shooting could kill his
passion for the sport Kamal karmali has
the inspiring story
just an ordinary fight it's something
never seen here before not just at this
BC Jiu Jitsu tournament but across the
province Leo Cimarelli paralyzed from
the waist down competing against
able-bodied Fighters and holding his own
they never seen anything that like that
or they even they never even thought
that it was possible it was his dream
for years but it was only this past
summer Samurai met the person who would
help get him there so I put my hook in
his coach Migo Ward Yasin I wouldn't say
it was difficult it was challenging I
needed to be creative but samarelli's
story goes back even further a boxer on
his way to turning pro in 2017 he was
shot four times police called it a case
of mistaken identities but he pushed on
without the use of his legs he climbed
to the Grouse Grind on his hands and
started a not-for-profit allowing boxers
with disabilities to compete
now creating new strategies to compete
against able-bodied Fighters what are
you looking at again I can I'm gonna be
looking for this okay so you you're
either for an arm I'm gonna be looking
for a leg I'm gonna be looking for a
double leg and or if you're even in
there reaching in there and depending
how I'm gonna be even going out for here
okay so you're looking to pull me into
you his first tournament handed him to
losses but still considered a success I
felt that made like a difference and um
and that I think is the most uh that's
the biggest Victory I came away from
that day the crowd inspired giving Leo a
standing ovation we all got emotional uh
I'm still getting choked right now
thinking about it now the next step to
notch a historic win it's rare to find
some guys out there like like me that
out there but there are people out there
in hopes more Fighters with disabilities
find the courage to roll onto the mat
Kamal coromali Global News
just remarkable that is global national
for this Monday night I'm nitu karcha
tonight's your Canada is the night sky
in Vail Mount BC thanks for watching
Donna will be back at the anchor desk
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]